[Musik]
guck mal mama ich glaube es ist auch
noch eine küche für elop
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit dem fall der die
[Musik]
da hab ich so teuer ja und die kleinen
die uns gefällt ja gar keine küche zu
mir ich glaube es führt kein weg dran
vorbei
dabei bauen uns eine küche fehler machen
wir ja so machen
[Musik]
da machen wir in waschbecken richter
doch dann sind und anders verteilt wir
versuchen jetzt eine kinderküche für
unter 25 eur zu bauen
für die kinderkirche braucht ihr
natürlich werkzeug einen teppich zum
schutz eures fußboden einen holzstuhl
eine holzplatte für die arbeitsplatte
ein holz für den regalboden ein holz für
die küchenwand und ein kleines holzstück
für die verstärkung
wir brauchen eine besteckschublade als
dunstabzugshaube eine farb wanne farbe
für den anstrich eine farb walze und
malerpinsel fürs waschbecken eine
schüssel oder einen futternapf einen
meterstab und hier habe ich noch 30 33
und 40 spax schrauben
wir fangen jetzt zuerst einmal mit der
arbeitsplatte abend die muss nämlich am
stuhl befestigt werden und die werden
wir jetzt zusammen bauen
und hier habe ich jetzt eine mehrschicht
holz und zwar den vorteil dass es nicht
sich nicht weg das ist einfach ein
bisschen stabiler jetzt einmal der
unterschied zu dem hier das ist ein
normales vollholz und das sieht man auch
schon je nachdem wie hoch die
feuchtigkeit auch mal ist dann verbirgt
sich das einfach ganz schnell und das
meer schicht material das erkennt man
auch hier im querschnitt ganz gut
normalerweise würde ich den stuhl jetzt
ein bisschen vor bohren damit ich es
einfacher haben den zusammenzuschrauben
aber ich habe samira als fleißiger
assistentin von daher geschaffen wir das
jetzt auch ohne vor bohren oder und
außerdem haben wir gerade nicht den
passenden fünf airborne maximal einen
tisch bringen
als unterlage
ja
[Musik]
man solle jetzt müssen wir aus damit er
schön in der mitte ist okay so krügel
ich habe hier bei mir ist null bei dir
okay ich mache jetzt hier einmal auf dem
brett die mitte und jetzt die stuhl
mitte und dann können wir die mitte
zusammenschieben ok damit die
arbeitsplatte nicht kommen team
ausgemacht da jetzt nicht verschoben
wird
wir kennen wir uns hier und hier
ok und erzählst du gut fest und ich
werde die zwei teile zusammenschrauben
zum zusammenschrauben nehmen wir einen
akkubohrer vorne habe ich schon ein
kreuz drin und für mich die wichtigsten
werkzeuge also eigentlich braucht man
echt nur vier zu hause
ich habe einmal den akku bohrer ich habe
ich einen heißkleber eine stichsäge und
hier noch einen tucker und das echt so
die grundausstattung und damit kann man
wunderbar basteln und vor allem viel
bauen
ok hast du schrauben
ja ich hab keine schrauben gesagt jetzt
fragen wir vier schrauben sofa und bei
den schrauben ist jetzt ganz wichtig
dass sie nicht so lange sind dh wenn ich
hier durchgehend dass ihr dran lege darf
es eben nicht höher sein als tisch damit
sich das kind eben auch nicht verletzt
und jetzt kann ich den stuhl und die
platte an vier stellen miteinander
verbinden
[Musik]
so haben wir schon mal schritt 1 als
nächstes ist das waschbecken an der
reihe und dafür könnt ihr zb einen hunde
foto abnehmen oder im katzen füttern ab
oder ihr nehmt nach einem eimer den
haben jetzt auch im baumarkt gefunden
und denen müssen wir hier noch durch
reinlassen das heißt ich muss jetzt hier
einen kreis ausschneiden der aber auch
nicht so groß sein darf soll er von
alleine halten und die ella kann er
später einfach in einem aufnehmen und
mit dem spielen
das heißt nicht mehr so ziehe einmal den
durchmesser und macht den kreis etwa
einen zentimeter kleiner 25 also 24 okay
und wir jetzt ein problem wir haben kein
zirkel das heißt wir bauen uns selber
ein und aus einer schnur und im stift
[Musik]
unser kreis mit der stichsäge sehen wir
jetzt hier diesen kreislauf damit ich da
jetzt gut reinkommen muss ich erst
einmal 23 löcher bohren damit einfach
das sägeblatt schön platz hat ich nehme
jetzt einfach den größten bohrer den wir
haben
du darfst jetzt den stuhl gut festhalten
oder setze ich am besten drauf und wenn
ihr noch eine dritte person habt oder
eine erwachsene person könnte er einfach
jetzt noch jemanden holen da eben den
staubsauger dran hält das machen jetzt
einfach im nachhinein okay also los
geht's
bei der stichsäge ist ein ganz dünnes
sägeblatt sei wichtig damit man gut um
die kurven kommt ich habe jetzt hier
einfach das dünnste genommen und
deswegen kann ich jetzt damit hier
ansetzen und den kreis schön
ausschneiden
der kreis ist ganz schön geworden oder
und wenn man schon beim sägen sind
runden wir diese ecken her auch noch ab
dafür brauchen einen runden gegenstand
zum beispiel so gut vorbereitet sein
können dass hier einmal anzeigt und auch
kurz wegschneiden
[Musik]
damit das holz jetzt beim schneiden
nicht reißt fange ich jetzt nicht hier
an der stelle an also gegen die faser
sondern ich scheide mit der phase
richtung die fahrrichtung erkennt ihr
hier dran also hier sieht man auch ganz
schön die streifen gehen ihnen die
richtung also fange ich hier an
zuschneiden und geht am so eine rechts
rum
[Musik]
erst einmal probieren ob das auch passt
was die mama hier gemacht hat also nicht
das problem sondern zeichen zu setzen
die vola das waschbecken ja weiter geht
kommen wir bauen jetzt auch die rückwand
hin und den regalboden jetzt schreiben
wir zuerst die rückwand an
und das machen jetzt mit hilfe von vier
schrauben einfach hier
das messen wir vorher kurz ab genau du
hättest die schrauben fest und ich
brauchs dann fest ok spektrum spax
schrauben
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der regal wurden dort bietet
sich das stuhleck passt jetzt sehen wir
dass nach vorne und müssen natürlich
wieder abmessen dass es in der mitte ist
okay und da müssen auch angesprochen und
das wetter paco von rechts und links
regal das regal verrät sitzt richtig
jetzt kann ich hier den stift nehmen und
einmal von unten den teil vom stuhl
kennzeichnen innen und außen jetzt das
regalbrett mit den linien nach oben auf
den stuhl legen und einfach an bord
wir beziehen die besteckschublade und
zwar kann man entweder daraus und regal
machen
so oder so ich hier drin bringen oder
auch abschneiden
wir werden daraus jetzt eine
dunstabzugshaube machen deswegen kommt
die hier einfach oben drauf kohl oder
und die müssen jetzt hier auch mit
schrauben befestigen einmal hier oben
und einmal natürlich auch schon hinten
okay wir bauen zusammen
jetzt steht schon mal die grundstruktur
damit allerdings der stuhl nicht umkippt
wenn die eltern arbeitet werden wir
jetzt hier unten noch zwei füße dran
machen dafür verwende ich etwas restholz
schneide es zu und borsten an
aber wir müssen schluss machen aber
morgen können wir wieder so machen wir
das
beim den tisch erfolgreich
zusammengebaut die küche ich glaube die
grundstrukturen stehen auch schon mal
kennt ansatzweise was es wird gibbs
schutz ist auch dran
morgen werden wir ihn abschleifen und
streichen und dann sind wir bald fertig
kaum gehen mal kekse essen haben uns
verdient oder jetzt geht es weiter mit
unserem tisch und zwar muss jetzt hier
ein bisschen was abgeschliffen werden
damit ella oder auch samira wenn sie mit
dem tisch spielen sich kein spieler
holen und dafür nehme ich jetzt einen
schlag schwamm und zwar hat der 120er
körnung und je höher die körnung umso
besser wird das ergebnis also umso
feiner ich brauche aber unterstützung
von da bist du kann mir schleifen ab und
dann könne man eben nicht sofort auch
schon den tisch anmalen und dafür nehmen
wir einen acryl bund lag und der ist auf
wasserbasis bist doch ganz wichtig hatte
kurz denn wenn wir das zum beispiel ist
auf die kleider bekommen können wir
gleich auswaschen vor allen dingen ist
einfach auch ein bisschen besser das ist
auch spielzeug geeignet und kann echt
super trocknen und ist für gegenstände
für innen und außen geeignet zum malen
verwenden wir einen acryl bund lag der
ist für innen und außen geeignet und auf
wasserbasis hergestellt
mir ist ganz wichtig dass er auch für
kinderspielzeug geeignet ist außerdem
lässt es sich ganz einfach wieder von
der haut mit einem silikon schwarm
abwaschen
[Musik]
24 stunden später ist unsere küche
getrocknet und wir können jetzt wieder
weitermachen
ich habe jetzt hier ein paar deko
elemente und zwar com jetzt erstmal die
doofen knöpfer dran
dafür habe ich auch stuhl vier löchern
gebohrt und hier diese grippe dran
gemacht und zwar haben wir die einfach
bei unserer freundin im keller gefunden
da können wir wirklich alte türgriffe
nehmen oder auch vom schrank einfach
griffe die gibt's natürlich auch neu zu
kaufen auch für kleines geld für ein bis
zwei euro
aber wir haben es natürlich nur versucht
dinge zu nehmen die wir schon da haben
beziehungsweise die wir vom sperrmüll
oder von freunden kostenlos bekommen
aber nicht bitte die knöpfe von omas
schrankwand schrauben die braucht ihr
bestimmt jetzt kommen die gardinenstange
und zwar ist es ja unser offen und er
braucht eine tür
dafür habe ich jetzt ne kabine genäht
und zwar passt die genau hier auf diese
öffnung und es kann man wirklich mit 12
stichen entweder mit der nähmaschine kur
zusammen nehmen oder ihr könnt es auch
per hand machen oder einfach zu
schneiden und ganz ohne nehmen hier
bringen wir jetzt zwei haken an
dann kann er den ofen auch immer schön
auf und zumachen und unten machen wir
noch eine stange rein und dann ist es so
ein bisschen beschwert
wer mit von opas alter küche einen
wasserhahn also eine armatur und die
bauen wir jetzt an und ich denke hier
außen weiß vielleicht 2000 ist man
vielleicht hier ja hier gott sondern man
dass hier die unterlegscheiben und die
schrauben also heißt jetzt bohren und
anschrauben
[Musik]
samira mal jetzt gerade mit acrylfarbe
eine kleine holzbox aus und das ist dann
einfach so einfach für utensilien in der
küche ich nehme mir jetzt den backofen
vor und zeichnete hier mit bleistift ein
paar linien vor und wetter mit schwarzer
voll ton und abtönen farbe noch den
backofen ausmalen mit der gleichen farbe
mal ich auch noch die herdplatten an und
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr einen etting
oder einen anderen permanentmarker
nehmen und noch einzelheiten hin malen
damit ella beim backen und kochen auch
etwas sieht bekommt sie noch kleine led
lichter aus dem baumarkt die sind auch
super günstig und man kann sie ganz
einfach an den dunstabzug leben unsere
kirche ist jetzt fertig und sie gefällt
uns und vor allem richtig gerücht noch
einkaufen denn ihre küche braucht er
auch noch eine ausstattung airlines
kannst du deinen corp holen mit den
töpfen genau braucht die beste
ausstattung nicht nur die küche ein
[Musik]
insgesamt haben wir gebraucht sieben
euro für holz und schnitt drei euro
fünfzig für die besteckschublade vier
euro 50 fürs waschbecken vier euro für
die schrauben und zwei euro für die
haken 1 euro 50 für die gardinenstange
zwei euro für die led-lichter der stuhl
die farbe der stoff und die knöpfe die
waren kostenlos die hatten wir nämlich
noch im keller übrig wir haben es
geschafft eine kinderkirche für unter 25
eur zu bauen
wichtiger als der preis ist aber das
selbermachen und das gemeinsame merkel
mit dem kind das selbe bauen stärkt das
selbstbewusstsein des kindes
kinder können oft viel mehr als die
erwachsenen ihnen zutrauen kinder
brauchen selbstbewusstsein damit sie
stark sind und an sich glauben die
eltern schenken ihnen aufmerksamkeit und
anerkennung ermuntern die kinder so dass
die eigenen fähigkeiten gestärkt und
gefördert werden
und das beginnt schon beim bau in einer
kinderküche das kind merkt dann hab ich
habe die fähigkeit ziele zu erreichen
häufig konzentrieren sich eltern im
alltagsstress auf das was kinder nicht
so gut können oder nicht schaffen
dabei ist es viel wichtiger den
blickwinkel zu ändern und zu schauen was
das kind eben schon gut kann lobte
kinder nicht nur mit worten sondern auch
mit gesten und blicken die einzelnen
fähigkeiten der kinder sollten gezielt
gefördert werden damit aus ihnen
selbstbewusster und glückliche menschen
werden
und jetzt wünschen wir euch viel spaß
beim nachmachen und beim spielen und
kochen und backen in eurer neuen
kinderkirche bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
hast du einkaufen und super sich aus
tätig
hey was geht
[Musik]